hello everyone i'm shutan
a senior researcher from microsoft
research asia
in this webinar i will introduce a
research work
that aims to push the frontier of neural
text to speech
uh before the sharing of this topic i
will give a
brief self introduction i am currently a
senior researcher at machine learning
group
in microsoft research asia and my
research
interests deep learning and its
application
on language language speech and music
processing
and the topics include text-to-speech
automatic speech recognition neural
machine translation
language speech for training and music
understanding and generation
and this is my homepage microsoft and
you can
follow more details and the research
work
through this home page and i also listed
our project page for the speech related
research
and you can find some demo samples
especially for
tedious research from this project page
and this is the outline of this
presentation and mainly consists of
three parts
in the first part i will give an
overview of text to speech
and briefly introduction uh a brief
introduce the technical species
synthesis and in the second part
i will introduce our research work that
aims to push
the frontier of neurotype to speech from
different aspects for the first aspects
we aim
to speed up the influence of
text-to-speech model
therefore so we developed a series of
research work including fast fast speech
and fast bd2
which are published in neural ips two
years ago
and this year's icr and with further
development night speech which is
published in
this year's icasp and for the second
aspect
we aim to beat end-to-end tds model
so we developed the fast pg-2s which is
published
along with fast pg-2 in this year's icr
and in the third aspect we aim to
develop the low resource text-to-speech
system
that can build with field training data
to support the tts for low resource
languages
so we developed the error speech which
is published in
last year's kdd and for the
first aspect we aim to build the tts
uh worst epic adaptation for the
customer voice scenario
so for this uh scenario we build a
series of tts research work
include other speech lsbc2 and rsd3
which are published in this year's icr
and icast
and other speech 3 is in submission
and in the third part of this
presentation will
have some discussion on tts and
make a summarization of this
presentation
and let's start with the first part
i will briefly introduce the text to
speech synthesis
tactical species synthesis which is
short for tds
refers to the artificial production
of human speech from text so the tedious
tds technologies has now have announced
story
the early tds system uh is built on
the concatenative species synthesis
which concatenates
recorded speech pieces that are stored
in your database and later
some statistical parametric specific
measures are proposed which uses
statistic
measures such as hidden markov model or
deep neural network network
to predict the acoustic features from
some
linguistic features and then use the
parametric encoder
to sensitize the speech waveform from
the acoustic features
and later as a development of deep
learning
the neural network-based end-to-end
species synthesis
uh system are proposed and which can
greatly
improve the naturalness and voice
quality of the species synthesis
basically speaking tactical speech
synthesis require
interdisciplinary technologies including
acoustics linguistics digital single
processing
statistic method and deep learning
next i will give a brief uh introduction
of
neural based entrant species synthesis
uh neurobased engine species synthesis
mainly consists of three components as
you can see from this finger it follows
the basic
model components from the statistic
parametric synthesis
the first component is text analysis
which converts the text sequence into a
phoneme sequence
and it requires some functionalities
such as text normalization
which can normalize the non-standard
text into standard text such as the
january the
libra opera variation for january and we
can convert into the
fully text of january and then we
conducted a graph into phoning
conversion
that converts a character sequence into
the following sequence
which can be better pronounced and if
the
one word have multiple pronunciations we
will
do the polyform disambiguation to
choose right pronunciation in the
context
and after we got the following sequence
the acoustic model
converts the following circuits into
male spectrogram
which is the acoustic feature uh for the
speech
and the acoustic model is usually built
on the uh
deep neural networks uh some famous
works such as taction 2
depository transformer tds and our fast
speech and fast b2
are a representative acoustic model
and after that the vocoder
converts the male spectrogram into
speech
waveform and different from the
vocoder in the statistical parametric
synthesis the vocal model
in the neural based textual speech
businesses
mainly adopted a neural based model and
some representative models that include
wavenet with rn rpc net
with growth and mere gain
okay so this is a brief introduction of
text to speech
and let's go to the second part
we will introduce our research work
that can push the frontier of the neural
textual speech
from the several aspects so in the first
aspects i will introduce our work
to speed up the influence of tactical
speech
so entering the neuritis model usually
adopts
the autoregressive male spectrum and
waveform generation
however the speech sequence is usually
very long
for example for one second speech there
are usually
500 friends of male spectrogram
and 24 000 within points
so it is a very long sequence if you use
the auto result generation
uh one point by one point or frame by
frame and the influence speed is very
small
as you can see from this finger this
finger proves the relationship
between the predicted male spectrum
length
and the inference time you can see that
the inverse time grows linearly with the
lens of the output sequence that means
that if you have
longer sequence the inference time will
be longer
so this is a problem uh we
so we've proposed fast speech to
adjust this problem to influence the uh
uh
to speed up the inference so let's
briefly uh overview the problems that
fast speech tries to solve previous
autoregressive tts model such as
techchunk 2
deeper 3 and transform tds suffer from
the following issues
the first issue is the slow influence
speed because there are user auto
reversal generation for the non-speech
sequence
and the second issue is not robust
their generative speech usually has
worse keeping
and repeating issues so you can
hear this voice so this voice is
generated by the auto recursive
transformations model
you can call me directly at four two
five seven zero three
four four or myself or two five four
four four four
seven four send me a me request with a
request with appropriate four
four four four or so you can hear
the jerusalem voice has a lot of
skipping and repeating issues
and for the third issue like the third
issue is lack of controllability
it is hard to control the worst speed
and porosity in the autocross generation
because the other regressive generation
generates the frame one by one
automatically
so uh to solve this problems we
propose fast speech as shown in the
right finger
this is a model structure of fast speech
there are three key designs in fast
speech the first
is we use a 54 transformer network to
generate the male spectrum in parallel
that means that means we do not use the
conventional autoregressive
encoder attention decoder model so
this greatly speed up the inference and
the second design is that we remove the
text-to-speech attention mechanism
between the phone encoder and meta
spectrum decoder
because we found a lot of repeating and
skipping issues are due to the incorrect
attention alignment so we totally
remove the attention mechanism instead
we
use a fade forward transformer with lens
regulator to
build the alignment between the text and
speech
and as a by-product it can be used to
control the duration of the synthetic
speech because we can adjust
the predicted duration shorter or longer
which can result in
the voice with a quicker or slower speed
so as a summary so fast speech has the
following
advantages the first is extremely fast
fast speech can have 217 times
inference speed up on male spectrum
generation and 38 times speed up on
final waveform generation and the second
advantage is robust the generative voice
by fast speech
has no bad case of worst giving and
rapidity
and third is controllable we can control
the voice speed and probably
through fast speech model and last but
not the least
fast speech can achieve on par or better
voice quality than the previous stay of
the
tds models so you can follow this link
to hear the demo samples here the
fast page so in terms of
product deployment fast speech has has
been deployed on microsoft azure
speech service to support the tts for
54 languages and locals so you can
defend from this table uh uh so
fast speech has supported the 54
different language and locals and you
can also
uh follow this link of microsoft
azure cognitive service to try the
td service that are powered by fast
speech so
now i will give a short demo uh
to show the voice generated by our
ir speech service and power by fast page
okay
this is a demo page of microsoft
azure text to speech service and in this
text box you can input any text and then
our engine will sense this as a speech
in real time
and so we can have a uh
show try so every type of text
text to speech synthesis
is interesting
okay and then we can choose different
languages so by default we use
uh english and we can choose different
voice and also different
uh voice style or speaking speed and
pitch so we can play
text to speech synthesis is interesting
yeah you can hear the jared voice and
maybe we can change some different
styles such as a question so we can hear
the voice
text to speech synthesis is interesting
so you can hear the the tone of this
sentence is changed
so i i can yeah
essential test text to speech synthesis
is interesting
oh yes and you can also change the
speaking speed
so i so i change the speed to be quicker
text speech synthesis is interesting oh
yes
and yeah maybe two create
text speech synthesis is interesting oh
yes
and you can also uh higher or lower the
page so
for example our uh lower the page
text-to-speech synthesis is interesting
oh yes
okay and you can also use other uh
speakers such as
chinese uh to generate the
english speech
text to speech synthesis is interesting
oh yes
so it can say the english speech uses
chinese style
okay this is all about fast pace
and next we introduce advanced version
of fast speech fast speech 2.
also fast speech has achieved good
success in both research and product
it still has improvement space
there are some problems in fast speech
the first is
the training pipeline is complicated
because fast fast speech uses a
two-stage teacher student destination
and second issue is the target is not
good because the target male spectrum
ground used by fast speech is distilled
from a teacher
that suffers from information loss and
the third is that the duration is
checked from the
attention map of the teacher model and
direction is not accurate
uh so we propose fast speech tool
and to improve the uh
issues in fast speech by the following
aspects the first is
we simplify the training pipeline remove
the
teacher student designation and only
only use one stage
training that use a ground choose a
speech as a target so this can also
avoid
the information loss of the distilled
uh tiger male spectrogram and the third
that is that we improve the duration
from
an alignment tool and at the same time
we introduce more various information
to ease the one-to-many mypin problem so
here we
introduce what is one too many mapping
in tts so the one-to-many mapping refers
to
that there are multiple speech
variations corresponding to the same
text
these variations include the duration
pitch
sun volume speaker style and emotion
so if there are not enough information
to predict this
speech variations the model tends to
over fade so by providing more
information such as the duration pitch
and sonoma as inputs
then the one-to-many mapping problem can
be
converted into a one-to-one mapping
problem this can ease the model training
and improve the generation
generation beauty of the tds model
so this is a model structure of fast
speech 2
and we use a variance adapter between
the phone encoder and mesh spectrum
decoder
and the valence adapter contains
a different variance predictors to
predict the duration pitch
and energy information during during
training the
merit spectrum decoder takes the ground
choose
duration and pitch energy manuals as
input but in inference
it takes a predicted values from this
variance predictor
uh for inference fast speech 2 improved
fast speech with
the following aspects the first is more
simplify training pipeline
and the second is higher voice quality
because we provide
more accurate duration information and
more accurate
targets and also more variance
information
and we can maintain the advantages of
fast
robust and even more controllable since
this is in fast speech
you can follow this demo page to hear
the sample generated by fast speech tool
and the fastb2 is also deployed on
microsoft azure tds service
so you can also follow this link to try
uh microsoft azure td service
okay next uh i will introduce an even
faster tds model light speech so
here we briefly introduce the background
of night speech
deploying tts model in mobile forms or
embedded devices
requires extremely small memory usage
and inference latency
also fast speech can achieve a
significant
influence speed up but it is not enough
for the
scenario of embedded devices because it
still has
a lot of model size and computation
so further speeding up the influence of
fast speech
and reducing the model size are
necessary
so we propose a light speech we mainly
use the neural architecture search
to search for lightweight and efficient
architectures
here we use a famous uh
a a good neural architecture
search algorithm gptnas for the search
as you can see from uh this table
uh compared with fast speech 2
light speech cam
has have a much fewer model parameter it
can reduce the parameter by 15 times
and also reduce the computation by 16
times
and in in terms of the influence speed
it can speed up
by a 6.5 times
and in terms of the worst quality as you
can see from this finger
light speech can show on par
voice quality with fast speech 2 but
with much fewer parameters and
computations and
faster inference as a compression
we can directly reduce the model size of
fast speed 2
to match the size of the night speech
and you can see the quality
drops largely so this can demonstrate
the effective
of the effectiveness of light speech
for the lightweight and efficient
tedious synthesis and you can also
follow this demo link to hear the demo
samples during the
last speech okay but now we have
finished we'll
introduce the introduction of the first
aspect influence speed up
and next uh i will introduce our work to
build the
fully entrained tds model fastb2s
so before the introduction of our work i
will
give a brief background of the
engine tds model so
the advantages of entering the tds model
uh is that we re it requires
less human pre-processing and facial
development
and because we can change the model in
an entrance
and joint way so we can remove the arrow
propagation
in a conversion or cascaded tds model
which consists of consists of
text analysis acoustic model and a
vocoder
and you can also reduce the training
development and
deployment cost to build ttl systems
however there are great challenges to
build the entrant tedious model
the main challenge is that the learning
difficulty
from text to waveform
because the text and wifi are in
different modalities and
the sequences are are
have launched mismatched because for
example
for text sequence with 20 a word
and and by this corresponding switch
form
it corresponds in speech for a speech
waveform
can have 100 of thousands away from
points so
if we want to put the whole utterance of
the speech waveform
into the model training in a single
batch it will require a huge memory and
a computation cost
this causes difficulty to train the
engine to this model
and actually as the development of
neural based tts
the model uh
is progressively becoming end-to-end so
this
fingers shows this process of
progress aggressively end-to-end the
first
uh the rntv system uh
uses three components and the first
upper finger shows
the component components used in the
statistical parametric synthesis
it consists of three components text
analysis analysis
acoustic model and vocoder and later
some entrance models such as webinate
combines the acoustic model and our
coder together into a single neural
model that directly generates a speech
from the
linguistic features and
this can simplify the pipeline folder
and later some models such as taction
2 and deep voice 3 propose
uh the more clean
and neural based model that simplify the
linguistic features
and acoustic features so the only
general functioning sequence from the
text
uh from the text through the text
analysis
component and use the neural based
acoustic model to generate the mass
spectrum from the following sequence and
then use a neural based of a coder
to generate speech from the male
spectrogram
and later some fully
entering the ts model is proposed that
can directly generate the speech
from the text such as a model carnet or
childhood wave
and next i will introduce
our model fast p2s which is uh
the first tts model with fully parallel
text to wave uh generation
that means that uh unlike the previous
engine model
chart wave or carry net fast speech 2s
can fully generated the waveform from
text
in parallel because we can see that the
chart with
our current net jerry's acoustic
features
or they will form uh in an
auto-regressive
uh way but our model can uh generate
all the waveform in parallel which can
speed up the inference
um in order to achieve the end-to-end
model training
and generation we use use the
adversarial training for the welfare
generation and
add an auxiliary mirror spectrum decoder
to improve their representation learning
and you can follow more details of
of the fast speech 2s from our paper
okay next we will introduce our research
work to be the
lowest of tts uh system that can be
applied to support the low resource
languages
and we first introduce the background
the low resource tts
there are 7 thousand languages in the
world
but the popular commercialized speech
service such as microsoft azure
google cloud and aws only support dozens
of languages there are
there is strong business demand to
support more language in the tds
uh not only for business but also
for the social goods because there are
uh so many
language in the world and and
a lot of languages are are in danger
however the data collection cost is very
high for this extremely low resource
languages
for example we have some statistics and
calculation
that to build one low resource language
the minimal data labeling cost
will be one meaning uh so if we want to
support so many languages
that will cost a lot of money
so they propose air speech
to be the lord resource tts and also sr
systems
so error speech consists of three stages
in the first stage we leverage the
language transfer
that we can purchase the tts and sr
model
uh from the rich resource languages
and then fan tuning the models on low
resource languages
so this leverages the facts that the
human languages
share similar pronunciations and the
ritual resource language data
is really easy to get and after we
obtain the
protein model and and fan tuning on this
model
uh in the second step we leverage the
textual speech and automatic speech
recognition models
to help with each other so this can
leverage the task
duality of these two tasks with
unpaired speech and text data and can
boost
the performance of the two models
gradually and iteratively
and after the first two steps we have
already
got a good tds and sr model
and in the third step we can customize
these models
for product deployment with knowledge
destination
it can improve the accuracy
of the tts and asr by the technology
destination and we can also customize
the multispeaker tds
to attack a single speaker tds and which
can
be used for the product scenario and
also
to customize to a smaller model such as
fast speech
so this is a pipeline of er speech and
here it shows the experiment results of
our speech
we conducted we conducted the
experiments
on the sudo low resource language
english
and the truly low resource language in
sylvania
and you can see that air speech can
achieve
a high intelligibility rate
and most score and you can
follow this uh demo page to hear the
samples you read by air speech
and we also show the data cost to build
a lorry source tds system
of different uh low resource
tedious research works as you can see
that our air speech can greatly reduce
the
data cost compared with previous works
nearly by 100 times
and aerospeech has
already been employed in microsoft azure
tech to speech service to support the
five new law resource languages
including martinez misophania estonia
irish and nato via
[Music]
and you can follow this page to follow
the more details of our
lore resource languages supported by our
techniques
and here we come to we come to the last
topic a tedious voice adaptation and we
will introduce our research work on a
speech
series and
here we briefly introduce the background
a customer voice is an important service
in text to speech
some popular speech cloud service such
as microsoft azure
google cloud or aws or support the
customer voice service so in the
customer voice
center scenario it aims to
support the tds for the voice of any
users
or customers so in this scenario the
users need to record their voice
with their own devices but usually with
a few sentences
and then they can upload their recorded
voice
to the speech service a forward
adaptation
and the speech service can
adapt the virtual tedious model with
this
field adaptation data and then the tds
model can support the voice
for this yoga or customers and then the
speech service service model
for the inference in this scenario
there are a lot of challenges so we
summarize the challenges
in this scenario in this scenario and we
conduct
the corresponding research to address
these challenges
the first challenge is that usually in
the customer waste
scenario the user usually recorded a few
adaptation data
and and also we
need to use few adaptation parameters to
support
the single speaker because if we want to
as many users or customers as possible
if we want if we use too many adaptation
parameters the
total memory storage will be huge
and another issue is that usually the
voice recorded by the user uh have
uh have different acoustic conditions
that they can
record it use their own devices in their
own knowledge environment or using their
own
speaker speaking styles so these
acoustic conditions are very different
from the specific data that we used to
train the soft tts model
so for these challenges we proposed out
of speech
which is published in this year's icr
and
for the second challenge uh because
usually
we can easily get the untranscribed
speech of the user but not the pair the
textual
text and speech data of this user for
example
we can usually get the data of this user
in the
online meetings or conversations without
the corresponding transcript
transcription so how can we leverage
the plenty of untranscribed speech for
the adaptation
so we propose other speech 2 to
solve these challenges and
usually for the third challenge
usually our speech are recorded in the
reading style
but usually in our daily conversations
or in the talks
in the podcast or or online speech
our speech are usually spontaneous that
means there are
a lot of different
reason patterns or the fade powders such
as
um or are in the speech but currently
the
tedious technology is mainly for reading
style speech
and to support a spontaneous speech
it is challenging so in for the third
challenge we
propose lsb3 uh to support that he has
four spontaneous styles
and which is in a paper submission and
and next ever briefly introduced three
works
uh the first is out of speech so for the
adaptation scenario we mainly use a
three-stage pipeline that will first
change uh of a source t-test model on
the large-scale muddy speaker
speech data and then fine-tune the
version to this model
uh on the field adapting data for a
specific
url speaker and then use this adaptation
model for the inference for this
speaker and
so i will recap these two challenges as
we mentioned before
the first is to support diverse
customers the adaptation model needs to
handle diverse
acoustic conditions which are very
different from the soft speech data
and the second is that we want to
support a lot of
customer users as possible we need to
reduce the adaptation parameters for
example
if each user or voice needs
100 mb storage for the
adaptation parameters if we want to
support 1 million users the total memory
storage
storage will be 100 pb so
that is a huge storage um
however the previous work either
have too many adaptation parameters or
have two poor adapting quality with
few parameters and one important issue
is that the only considered source and
the adaptation data are in the same
domain
so we propose out of speech and
this finger shows the model structure of
other speech
and it is built on the basic model
structure of
fast speech 2 by designs two
key components to address the challenges
the first is the
acoustic condition modeling
that it can model the diverse acoustic
conditions at a different
level such as speaker athletes and phony
levels and which can
ensure the model can support the
different
acoustic conditions for the speech
uploaded by the
user or speaker and the second component
is condition
neural normalization in the merge
spectrum decoder
it uses
some uh linear layer to calculate the
scale and bios in the layer
normalization from the speaker embedding
so by this way we can fine-tune as a
smaller parameter as possible while
ensuring the
good was quality and we also consider
the adoption data in different
uh acoustic conditions
from the source data this is more
challenging but
close to the product scenario and here's
your the experiment with that
we change the source model on the
liberties data set and
adapt to the earlier speech with dega
and the neighbor tds dataset
with 20 sentence for each speaker
and you can see from this table that
other speech can achieve
better quality with similar parameters
and achieve um power quality with much
fewer adapting parameters compared with
the previous spacetime and you can also
follow this demo link to hear the sample
series above other speech
and you can see the last speech has
already been deployed
in microsoft azure speech to support the
customer voice scenario and you can also
follow this link to try the customer
voice
supported by microsoft azure speech
and here we go to the next uh
work out speech 2. as we mentioned
before
other speech 2 is many to support the
adaptation
with untranscribed data because we can
easily get
a lot of untranscribed data but not the
text and
speech repair data so we designed our
four-step
pipeline to support the adaptation with
untranscribed speech
and many uses speech reconstruction with
the latent
alignment in the first step
we use we regularly train a social
status model
with multi-speaker data and in the
second step
we use another male spectrum encoder
and to conduct a special reconstruction
with the merge spectrum decoder but we
only
change the parameters of the main
spectrum encoder
and this and at the same time we
constrain the latent from the
phone encoder and the merge expression
encoder
to be the same space
so this can ensure that the main encoder
can be
an external component but but not
drive the latent space
far away from the original tts model and
in the third step we conducted speaker
adaptation
that we still use a special construction
for the with the untranscribed speech
data
and in in this step we only adapted the
mail spectrum decoder but
fix the mail special encoder because we
in the
second step we have already constrained
the
latent space of the two encoders in the
same
space so uh afterward we adapted the
mere spectrum encoder
or merge expression decoder based on the
measurement encoder we can easily
inference the speech based on the phone
encoder
so in the first step we can use the
original
phone encoder melody coder to inference
the speech
and this table shows the experiment
results
we still train our source
tds model on the label tds and adapted
to the earlier speech and with dj
with 50 untranscribed sentence
and you can see from this finger that
aspect achieves
sb2 achieves better quality than
previous measures
and achieves empire quality with the
untranscribed
adaptation here we use the other speech
as a baseline that means that we
can only use the untranscribed speech
to achieve the empower quality with the
transcript
data and you can also follow this demo
link
to to hear the demo samples generated by
fast page 2.
and next i will briefly go through the
third work out speech 2 rsv3 to support
the
spontaneous style species synthesis
you can see that the current tts voice
mostly focus on the reading style speech
but spontaneous style voice is useful
for the scenario like our danny
conversations
but there are some challenges to support
spontaneous style
the first is the lack of spontaneous
data because usually our data set is
recorded in the in in the recording
studio which is a reading style
but not usually the daily conversation
the freestyle
and there are also difficulty in
modeling
the distinctive characteristics in the
spontaneous speech such as the failed
powders
such as a brick like um or r or the
diverse reasons because in the
spontaneous styles
people usually lend or shorten their
their word or
increase or decrease their pitch of the
speech
so you can hear this voice
in spontaneous style accessory package
and all of that um yeah
so so you can hear that there are some
feed powders such as the n
or some some word here and there are
long break
between the the words so it's very
different from the normal reading style
speech
so for these two challenges we propose a
corresponding
component to solve these issues for the
lack of spontaneous data
we propose a method to mine the
spontaneous data set
from their website and
also considering the lack of training
data we
still build a spontaneous tds model
through the adaptation uh way that we
can change the
associated or source tds model on the
multi-speaker reading style
of speech data and then fine-tuning the
model uh
with a spontaneous style that can only
require a few
spontaneous speech data uh to ensure the
model can generate this
this style and and to solve the second
challenge we
design some specific modal structure
to predict the failed pulses and
to model the diverse reasons and
these tables show the statistics of our
mind data set we mainly come consist of
three subsets uh for the field powder
uh adaptation and the reason adaptation
and the temporal adaptation
and this model structure shows a
model of the other species three and we
mainly build the
model structure based on other speech
and use the
fp predictor to insert some
fade parts such as m or r in the text
sequence
and use the some
mixture of expert based duration
predictor to adapt the reasons
and also adapt the speaker temporal
that can synthesis the voice for any
target speaker that with spontaneous
style
and for the experimental results you can
see that other species three can achieve
better voice quality and similarity
than the previous baseline measures such
as other speech
in this scenario other speech you can
just use a
conversion adapting pipeline to adapt
the voice for the spontaneous tts
and you can hear some samples
again for these samples uh we can first
hear the uh ground choose audio
accessory package and all of that um
yeah so okay for this text we can
hear the voice generated by other speech
cecily package and all of that mva stuff
yes you can you can hear the speech is
not so
natural and you can hear the voice
cherished by anna's p3
satellite package and all of that um
yeah
so so you can hear that the voice chair
series by rsp3 can have very natural
and the brick and it it's very similar
to the sponge hanger style
that are used in the daily conversations
and we can also insert some fade pulses
into the text which is which originally
it does not have the fade pauses and we
can hear the voice
before they feed the powders in
insertion
six spoons of fresh snow peas five thick
slabs of blue cheese and maybe a snack
for her brother bob
and we can hear the voice after we
insert the
feed powders six spoons of fresh snow
peas
um five fixed labs of blue cheese and
maybe a snack for her brother bob
okay so after we insert the fade powders
this
speech can uh sound more spontaneous
okay but now we have uh finished the
introduction of the main part
that our research work to push the
frontier of the neural texture speech
and in the second part i will
have some short discussion and make a
summary
some make a summary for our presentation
and here i want to briefly discuss
about our tedious research
how to shift our divided research
frontier to consider the product
scenario
and this table shows some
difference between the tds research and
product deployment
and usually for the tds research we
mainly consider
the research work is non-trivial and
useful and usually cares more about the
novelty and deep
investigation on the long-tail solutions
so
the advantages of of the of the research
labs in their principle
and also in the good experiment results
and it's more storage driven to solve
scientific
problems but for the product it cares
more about the practice
practically useful even if it is not
novel or non-travel
but it is useful and it it
it also requires 99.9
usability but not the cherry pick cases
so it is a many for practical deployment
so uh basically speaking it is more
difficult to solve a
product problem than publishing a paper
so for example maybe you just need three
months to rush a good paper
but it takes one year to ship it into
the product
however i'm not saying that the research
is not important research has its great
value and
is in irreplaceable for the tts
product scenario we just need to take
the practical usage into consideration
during rtts research
so here are some aspects that we can
consider
when we're conducting our tts research
the first aspect
is that the product scenario we still
care about the voice quality that we can
improve the intelligibility
naturalness robustness expressiveness
and contribution of the
synthesis voice so the model may be not
the entrant but need to be accurate and
so
the the fully entered model may
discard the the textile validation
graphing to funding conversion but
by so far the this component is very
important to ensure the accuracy of the
pronunciation in product scenario and
because the product scenario cares more
about the
usability so we can uh it
can do more research work to avoid the
bad cases such as
glitches hoarseness mechanic nausea a
jitter or pitch break
in this incessant speech and we can also
consider some
other practice scenarios such as a
non-form paragraph
paragraph reading with emotion or
spontaneous style
and for the another aspect that we can
reduce the
development cost because if we want to
serve the model online or
in the product scenario uh the developer
development cost is a is a is a major
work
so for example we can build a universal
money speaker martin lingo money style
to this model and only thank you this
model to any
product scenario this can save a lot of
our engineering work
and we need also care about the
inverse latency the memory usage and the
computation cost
when we deploy deploy the ts model
in the server or especially in the azure
devices and we also
need to consider the data efficiency how
can we develop
developers model to build a high quality
ttl system but with fewer speech data
and to enhance the economy of the tts
product scenario we can also conduct
some uh consider some extended scenarios
such as senior voice synthesis and
talking phase
uh since this is this is the
great extension of the tts
conversion tds scenario so as a summary
of this presentation tds technology
evolves from concatenative synthesis
statistics
parametric synthesis and neural based
antenna
and the mentioned mainstream tedious
model you use a separate acoustic model
in the vocoder model
but the fully entered model is underway
and a lot of research work
are conducting in this direction
and for the practice practical usage
improving the quality while reducing the
cost is always the goal of tds
so the quality includes the
intangibility
naturalness robustness expressiveness
and controllability
and for the cost we can reduce the
engineering costs
by such as building the international
model or the serving cost
to speed up the inference or the data
cost we can be the lowest of tts
a system to build a model with
fewer data and research
is the engine for tds improvement and at
the same time
this engine should take care to should
take the
practical usage into consideration
okay so this is the all of this
presentation
and this page shows a paper list of our
research work and introduced in this
presentation
and this page shows our research work on
speech
okay that's all and this is the end of
this presentation
and later we will have 50 minutes
q and a session and welcome the
questions and discussions
thank you
uh okay so this is the end of this
uh talk and thank you for
your watching and now we come in
to the qa session
so i thought there are a lot of
questions during the video presentation
so i have already answered some of the
questions
and in this conversation i will
describe more details about some of
these questions
uh so
for the questions about
okay from university of rochester
so the question is that instead of use a
teacher model to extract durations for
the
funding how to get around get get a
ground choose durations in fast pc2
uh yeah i think it is a very good
question because
in textual speech the duration is very
important because the
input sequence is text and output
sequence is speech
the length of the two seconds is very
different
so uh for the uh sequence to sequence
modeling
uh because you can see that tts is gener
is a is a basic
is a basic segment to sequence problem
we need to model the lens mismatch so
you can see that in the auto regressive
model such as the encoder attention
decoder they use the attention
to connect the
text and speech uh even if there have a
differentness
but in the non-auto regressive
generation
uh so in the parallel generation such as
fast speech or fast b2
because we need to generate a speech in
parallel so we need to
uh we need the duration to expand the
text
to match to the length of the speech so
here we
need to get a duration so actually there
are a lot of method to get the origins
so it's very common uh it's a common
issue in the
conventional uh tts model so before the
uh deep learning comes out uh we have
the tds has
uh has a non-history uh to use the
uh statistical parametric synthesis so
so the duration prediction is also a
problem in statistical parametric
synthesis
so i have answered the question uh
writing a test about
the the different methods about the
duration model such as
asr mode or hmm mode or cdc model so
basically the sr mode or hmm
based mode or series muscle is is uh
it's all about the it's very like the uh
it's very similar to the automatic
automatic speech recon condition
so basically you can input the text and
speech
so the sr model can get the alignment
such as a hidden markup model or the
city set because the cdc path
can automatically calculate the
alignment between the text and speech
so in fast page 2 we use the open source
tool
called material fossil alignment it is
it is based on the hmm model
and there are so for tds for the
neural-based djs there are a lot of
other works
to design other alignments between text
and speech
such as the
work from demand the
the paper title is ancient uh uh
uh entrance adversarial text-to-speech
they they design another kind of
alignment
that can be trained with the
tds model or the
work such as glottites they design
another method
called monotonic alignment search to
search the alignment between the text
user
you you using a dynamic programming and
measure so
for the alignment modeling is so it's a
very a big
problem or a big topic in tts
yet so if you have interest you can to
get more details or to find some more
papers about how to model the alignment
in dds
and so for the
next question about the chain data
so uh yeah because you can see in this
presentation
we have uh introduced different
scenarios for the tts
such as the normal tds so for the first
speech of sp2
we conduct experiments in the public
urgent
data so it is a data set that consists
of uh more than 20
hours speech data and high quality and
single speaker data but
uh we also introduce the settings in
low resource scenario there are
a very limited paired data maybe just
several minutes or thousands of minutes
so in this scenario
we can also build a tts model
so we can leverage some techniques such
as
leverage the pre-training from other
uh languages because language in speech
all
share similar uh characteristics so they
can
you can transfer from other languages
and any other scenario such as tts was
adaptation
so in this scenario uh because we have
already have some
training data for one language but we do
not
have so much data for a certain speaker
so in this
scenario maybe for this target speaker
we just need
a several seconds of speech
and then it is enough to adapt the
source model to support the target
speaker
so uh you can see that for different
scenarios the data requirements
uh are different but but basically
speaking for industrial
model or for such as uh for the model
used in azure
as a microsoft azure tts service so the
data
yeah the user is very very notch so they
can
combine all the data to to change a very
very large model so the
quality will be stable and and be
robust to any uh scenarios
okay uh and for the
last questions uh
uh yep from xin anjang
so the question uh 15. so uh when
designing the neural acoustic model for
fast pc2
uh is there any consideration of
inductive bios
that specifically adjusts uh
or distinguished between phone and
duration pitch
uh yeah i i think i i think yeah
so there is some in value bios because
uh in
so you can see that in fast speech we do
not consider the
uh pitch or some other information
but in fast p2 we have a specific design
for this acoustic feature such as
duration and pitch and energy
uh because you can see that for uh in
speech
you can factualize the content or the
the the information in us in speech
into different categories uh including
the content
the content means what you see so it is
really
related about it it's related to the
text
or the phone in sequence it's about what
what to say
and the second aspect is about it it's
about how to say
uh that means you can use uh which paper
or which
timber to to say
this voice and the other aspect is about
prosody so how to say
so so the second is who to say who says
about the speaker characteristics but
the third
aspect is is how to say then how to say
uh we usually refer it to it as a
process and the processor
uh basically consists of different
features such as pitch
pitch reverse how so the frequency
you can say in the voice and the
duration that means that you
how how long you can say each phoneme
so actually we indeed
leverage the inductive bios because for
a processor
it can basically consist of pitch
direction and energy because energy is
uh relative related to the volume the
sound volume of the speech
uh yeah so so this is all about the
inductive bias i think it is very it is
a good
way or a good thinking about
how to leverage the impact inductive
bias of a speech
to address or to model the
species aware because simply using
the neural model is not enough
uh to address the challenges in terms of
speech or the speech problem
we need to to investigate or go deep
into the characteristics of the species
itself
and then in that way you can design more
powerful method to address the problems
and for the
last questions
so how can we distinguish fast speech at
a speech and nice speech
were used in speech sdk is there any
example
project which provides all types of
speech example uh yeah so
yeah it's a good question because
uh if people are not familiar or
if people so you can basically divide
the works from two aspects the first is
uh for research and the second
for the sdk it is for product or for
industry usage uh basically speaking
fast speech added speech or ar speech or
some other light speech this is just the
name of a research work
uh yeah so the research work is focused
on uh
addressing uh specific problems but in
terms
of a product i think you can see the
fast speech
or light speech they are addressing a
problem
that you need to generate a speech
in fast speed or in night with a model
so you can
serve in the industry online service
such as microsoft azure uh detailed
service because in online servers if
the model is very small or very huge
the latency is very big so we cannot
afford this latency so basically we are
addressing this problem
in the online survey so about the sdk
so you may be a jury you can
follow this link to try the
the uh speech service uh
to try the so i can just send
the link here so i'm not sure
if you can say the message
the link i i send so this is a
home page of the microsoft azure speech
service
uh so from this service you can
find a lot of different services for tts
basically
it is api uh
like i just apply in the video so i have
show some case or demo cases using the
uh
with api so you can try
this api so this api is basically the
the the ensemble of all the techniques
so as you can see the fast speech speech
live speech
so they are addressing each
specification problems
but they are all integrated into this
area
service and then you can uh try this
service through
this api and and and for added speech
because it is for the customer voice
scenario so that means that you can
uh adapt to the voice adapter teaches
model
uh to a certain speaker maybe just using
a similar second speech or five sentence
or 20 sentence
then you can get a tedious model to
support your voice
so we also have uh has another
uh homepage for the customer voice
and now we are so so it is
it is it is zero available so the
customers can
try the service by providing uh their
recorded data to adapt the model to
their voice
okay so i i hope that this can
answer your questions about the speech
sdk
okay so uh
now so if you have i think i have go
through
all the uh questions so if you have some
uh
further uh questions you can
ask uh in the spotter uh
uh yep so i can
continue uh to uh describe or something
about this
uh presentation or talk because in this
talk you can see that i
just mentioned some of some of the
challenges in terms of speech including
uh
building the fast tds or the
uh low risk of tts their
open problems in text-to-speech service
uh
texas b service that need us to
uh address uh such as
so the maybe the one of the most
important
question or uh the the problem in tts is
about
the core quality the quality of this
invoice or the
expressiveness because you can see the
speech generation is about content
generation
so we care more about the quality or the
emotion or the style
of this generous species if it is
similar to the human speech because now
you can
maybe when you try when you're using the
detailed service uh maybe not
only microsoft but other tds service you
can
you can maybe you can easily distinguish
that oh okay this is this was is just by
a machine and this voice is just by a
human
so you can easily distinguish the
machine generator speech and human
speech
so this is what we need to do to improve
the naturalness
the emotion the the expressiveness to
make
it more similar to the human or
uh for example if you try the service
that the
audiobook so there are some app you can
hear
the the so you can listen the book
uh the the audiobook and so some
some abb have tried the tts service to
read the book
and then you can just listen instead of
reading or
reading the book so uh but by the
problem is that
when you're reading a non-paragraph
uh because the the the voice generated
by the
uh model do not have
too much changes so yeah you were
quickly very
boring because there are no changes but
a human you can you can you can see that
if a human reading a book there will be
emotion
and there will be a change or or
variations or some something like that
so you can feel more comfortable
or are ever more good about
about reading by human but not reading
by
a tedious model so a lot of work has
come down to
how to control or control the emotion or
improve the expressiveness
so if you have um interest in this area
uh uh or you
want to try some do some research work
uh in the
tds domain so you can yeah you can go
into
more details about the uh problems
uh actually we uh
in this uh uh
maybe in the coming uh several weeks we
we will publish more uh details about
the
a paper about the how to address the
questions in
tts uh scenario
it's about it's more about a
comprehensive summary about about the
current status of the tds
uh research and if you have interest you
can
you can
keep an eye on what we uh what are
so so when our paper is coming out
uh so uh yeah this is there is a new
question
uh uh is there any github
uh uh is there
is there any given project where all
research work is being implemented
in implementation or maybe
uh is having all the latest changes i'm
looking for mobile
gaming use ut 3d so uh
for tds project i think there are some
uh open source github project to
implement
or some of the or some of the represent
representative
tds research work such as
yeah i can just send some of the
toolkit such as the
espnet so you can check
the toolkit here
yeah so this toolkit is uh
basically a very general toolkit about
the automatic speech recognition
and attack to speech or some other
uh tasks such as voice conversion uh
yeah so so some basic speech
tasks are incorporated into this uh
ripple
uh so you can have uh a start
from this kind of uh github repo or you
can just search in github to find some
popular
sound ripple with some purpose stars
okay uh so uh yeah
there is another advertisement that
in this summer in this ichika
uh yeah in this egg it's got
a 2021 conference we will give a
tutorial
about tactical speech and the time
is a quarter of day
so we will talk more about the neural
tactile speech
and the whole summary and the horse
array of the neurotypical species and
systems
in this area so uh if you
also attended each so ijci conference
uh this summer uh so you are invited to
attend this uh
tutorial so i have sent the link
into the question so you can
find our tutorial uh
called neural tactile speech
synthesis
yep
uh okay so there is a another question
so
okay so this is the last question that
we can uh discuss
uh so is that possible to use as a
training data to help spontaneous tts uh
yeah so uh because
uh for spontaneous tts uh
uh yeah for spontaneous tds so the
problem is that
uh the usu the zero data or the standard
data to trinity's model is a
audio book or is a reading style so you
usually ask
people to record or to to read a book or
read assumption
in an audio or you know in an
audio studio or recording studio so the
speech is very uh normal and
it's reading style but if you want to
change spontaneous
spontaneous style and you need to find
some data that
that is very similar to spontaneous and
airsoft data is a very good way because
the airsoft extra data is usually
collect uh
through the maybe people talking
conversation or
giving a lecture so in this scenario the
the
style of the data is very spontaneous i
think this
this kind of data can help uh the
uh to to build this model by you
you should uh uh
to take care about the quality usually
the airsoft sr data is usually
has poor quality this can make a
challenge to train a
tts model
yep okay so i think uh
this is all the uh questions and
if uh if the audience have more
questions you can
uh contact us through email so i have
already uh
leave the email into the in the in the
uh presentations in the video and
uh okay so the last advertisement
that a way in microsoft research asia so
we are machine learning a group
we are continuing conducting the
research on
text-to-speech or some other natural
language
and speech related research so if you
are
interested in our uh
so to to do an internship in microsoft
research asia so you can contact you can
contact
me and also if you are
just having to graduate this year or
next year and if
you if you are finding a job if you want
to do research
so you can also uh contact us
about the our ft job
okay uh thank you thank you so this is
all about this
webinar thank you for your attending uh
bye bye